we just had too many self self-imposed
you know mistakes and I think that's
that's what hurt us you know when you
put yourself behind like that it's hard
to catch up you know I think I could
throw the ball better we could catch it
better I think it's just a little bit of
everything
there's not one specific thing that
sticks out but you know it's a bit of a
reality check for us you know go back
and respond this week 49ers quarterback
Jimmy Garoppolo after the Monday night
overtime loss to the Seattle Seahawks it
was not a great game for Garoppolo
plenty of misfires and not the same kind
of confidence you'd want to have in the
quarterback of a team that's in
contention for the number one seed in
the NFC so Chris Simms on this Wednesday
edition to pft live we go what's more
likely and the first topic what's more
likely Jimmy Garoppolo is wearing a
49ers jersey in 2020 or playing for
another team I'm gonna go with the
option one that he's playing for the
49ers and 2020 I do I'm not ready to
panic on Jimmy Garoppolo yet yeah it
wasn't perfect the other night but like
he said they dropped passes man the two
tackles got dominated and you know their
first game back you know you heard Kyle
Shanahan in his press conference
yesterday saying they were rusty and
they certainly could have played better
attitude the fact that we said Jadeveon
Clowney was phenomenal so all those
things led to issues for Jimmy Garoppolo
but ultimately Mike I just look at it
and go you know even with this loss
somebody I just have a hard time
thinking the 49ers gonna be really any
worse than 12 and 4 and that's hard to
make any quarterback change when your
team is that good and wins that many
football games so I'm going with he's
there in 2020 you know I'm gonna go with
that for now
and I agree with you it's difficult to
do it when the team is 12 and 4 or 13
and 3 whatever the case may be but but
how he performs in the postseason
relative to Aaron Rodgers or Drew Brees
or Russell Wilson or Kirk Cousins if if
he plays poorly and and the way that I
could see it happen you play poorly in
the divisional round but your team is
still good enough to win then you play
poorly in the conference championship
round and you lose that's the kind of
thing that at least requires the 49ers
to do their due diligence and the
question becomes who else is out there
right what do you do with Garoppolo in
his contract
you can get out of it very easily by
cutting him you could trade him to
someone else he's got a twenty three
point eight million dollar salary next
year and they have until April one for a
large chunk of it to become fully
guaranteed so they've got that
flexibility they baked into all of their
major veteran contracts giving them time
to look at what's out there I think that
if he struggles in the postseason and
they don't get to the Superbowl they'll
at least look at what's out there but
the question is what's out there how do
you feel that you you know sufficiently
confident yes that you're gonna bring in
somebody who's better that's the devil
you know versus the devil you don't know
and also also also I think part of the
concern is he ends up back in New
England and he's better in New England
than he is in San Francisco in the Josh
McDaniels system and that's gonna
reflect poorly on the 49ers I think they
have to keep him for one more year
unless it's just a disaster in the
postseason
those last two points I think you're
they're very very strong and especially
you're right it's about what what is
what else is gonna be out there that's
better and you know you're not just
gonna get rid of a guy and then see what
happens so yeah I'm with you but there's
still a lot of evaluating and a lot of
ball to be played this season Kirk
Cousins at one point not that long ago
may have been available for Kyle
Shanahan but I have a feeling that the
Vikings are gonna happily pay the twenty
nine and a half million dollar base
salary for cousins next year all right
what's more likely Jared Goff bounces
back against Chicago or the Bears
defense shuts him down like they did
last year when they got together in
Chicago I'm going with option two the
Bears defense shuts them down III am I
mean we've seen them weigh the Rams have
looked I mean this Bears defense is
still one of the best in football now
their offense is an issue too but you
know I just think you know with the
state of the Rams offensive line and
then you know you're losing your center
and Rob haven't seen the right tackle is
not going to be playing this week and
some of the predictable nature of the
Rams offense right now you know the Rams
got to change it up they can't play one
tight end one running back three wide
receivers every play all game long they
make it very easy on defenses that way
it's too much of that personnel set but
yeah I'm going with the Bears defense I
think there's still a really really good
unit
one point that hasn't nearly gotten the
attention that I think it should have
this weekend there's so much going on
you can't focus on every little detail
the idea that facing a key third down
Sean McVeigh took Jared Goff off the
field and brought in your guy Blake
bortles for some sort of ill-conceived
read option like if you've got a
franchise quarterback you trust him in
that spot to make a throw have we got an
answer on that yet Mike I'm glad you
brought this up because I watched the
film in this game yesterday and now the
play before goth took a really good shot
so I don't know yet whether that was
intentional or they said it was here's
the play they said it was oh my gosh
then it was a disaster because like
Blake bortles came in looking like he
was cold and not warmed up and he
bobbled the snap and I think messed up
the play in general I don't know what
happened and if we continue to show this
play look he I don't know if he was look
he didn't know do I hand it off what do
I do I mean it was it was a disaster so
I yes that was not a good look in
general thank you for not saying one of
the various words that I feared you were
going to say when describing that play
one of which begins with the term
cluster look here's here's the thing
during the game itself I was watching
this live as we were scrambling to get
ready for a football night in America
and the thinking was that that there was
an injury to Jared Goff when he got
slammed into the ground but then he
never saw the trainers and it looked and
it was like what something's going on
here and after the game Sean McVeigh
said that was deliberate that was
intentional that was planned and I can't
help but wonder when you look at how
ugly that second down play was you just
wonder whether or not McVeigh just had
kind of a fit of a fury right he keeps a
lot of that bottled in you don't see it
come through and he said get that guy
the hell off the field let's put Blake
in there and run you know the play that
they've been holding in their back
pocket for a spot like this right and
cuz it's obvious Blake bortles wasn't
ready no he wasn't ready to come in and
do anything no he definitely wasn't a
yeah you see that replay again he's you
know again I don't know if he was
supposed to keep it or supposed to hand
it off and you know try to make the
defense think he might keep it but it
was not smooth the execution of the play
and what
I would say more than anything is there
a team that's got two or three running
backs right now just put one of the dam
running backs in it Wildcat quarterback
and let them run the freakin ball okay
I mean Blake bortles yes he's big and
strong and he is one of the better
running quarterbacks in football but
he's not Todd Gurley or Mack Brown or
Derek Darrell Henderson either and I
would rather had seen that than Blake
bortles taken around the edge against
the Steelers front seven at a time when
there's a lot of people who think the
NFL has caught up with Sean McVeigh if
this is what he's got to get ahead of
the curve he'll figure it out he'll
figure it out let's hope he does don't
know if it does here but he'll figure it
out he's too smart of a guy to not I do
believe that so I don't know if he can
figure it out all this year because they
got a lot of issues but I do have faith
in Sean because he's one of the more
intelligent guys I've ever been around
in football all right let's keep this
rolling with a couple of quarterbacks
who are playing extremely well which
quarterback is more likely to win the
game between Baltimore and Houston late
this week would it be Lamar Jackson or
deshaun Watson well man this is a tough
one I'm going with his Sean Watson
though because I think the Sean Watson's
you know he's on that rare list of gosh
he's you know not as good a runner as
Lamar Jackson but damn it's it's not
that far off he's really good runner and
then his throwing and ability to extend
plays and throwing is greater than Lamar
Jackson at this point that's where he
has the edge in that department plus
they're more a little more executed or
have a little more of an offense to
execute in those situations where you
know I don't we haven't really seen the
Ravens have to go down and oh we're down
by four or five points and we need to
now throw the ball because there's only
a minute and 20 seconds left and we got
to rely on the passing game they haven't
been put in that situation yet deshaun
Watson has and I've seen it a number of
times whether it was Clemson or the NFL
career and he's as good as anybody in
the business right I mean I don't know I
mean it made Russell Wilson and Aaron
Rodgers or maybe the only two guys I can
think of that are better than him in
those situations brady but he's in that
that short conversation of that short
list yeah and look we've seen deshaun
Watson make those clutch plays now we
just
Lamar Jackson make spectacular plays at
any time in the game right deshaun
Watson we do have that that history that
memory of making the big play making the
clutch play I don't know I got to choose
one of the other I'm going with deshaun
Watson but it did very well could be
Lamar Jackson which team under 500 is
more likely to pull off an upset this
week Atlanta against the Panthers or
Tampa Bay against the Saints I'm gonna
go with Atlanta I got to think New
Orleans is still that was I think a blip
on the radar
last week I still think New Orleans is
one of the best teams in football and I
think that kind of loss I'd be scared if
I'm Tampa Bay because they'll be pissed
off this week and you're gonna deal with
the New Orleans team who's been a you
know awoken by a bad performance
you know Atlanta Carolina you know I
just don't think Carolina Carolina's
good that but they're not as good as the
New Orleans Saints right and Elena does
have some things that scare you on their
team I mean you know they got Grady
Jared they got two really fast
linebackers and Lena changed it up on
defense a little last week Mike I mean
I've only been asking them to do that
for two years now and they found a
little bit of a running game too so if
I'm gonna pick one I'm gonna say Atlanta
yeah and I think Atlanta has every
reason to try to continue the momentum
you squander what you did last week if
you don't show up and give the Panthers
everything they can handle a Panthers
like we saw it last year they fell apart
down the stretch and we'll see if
they're in the process of falling apart
again
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports